un nouveau site à quelques mètres
seulement pour continuer à accompagner
les femmes victimes de violence
l'extension de la maison Calypso devrait
voir le jour d'ici 2024 depuis son
ouverture en janvier 2022 le premier
établissement accueilli 187 femmes le
plus grand succès pour
Calypso ce sera quand elle pourra fermer
quand on aura plus besoin de nous voilà
alors bon le monde est monde et on s'est
malheureusement que ce besoin
va perdurer dans le temps on a cinq six
pièces on voit bien que les besoins sont
plus importants que ça puisque le
parcours d'une femme peut durer un an et
demi c'est pas on la voit une fois et
puis ça s'arrête là non elle a besoin de
venir de revenir de cheminer à besoin de
participer à des ateliers de
reconstruction de soi et donc ça prend
ça prend du temps
inspiré de la Maison des Femmes de
Seine-Saint-Denis Calypso regroupe une
douzaine de praticiens sage-femme
conseiller conjugal psychologue un
développement qui a attiré l'oeil de la
délégation droit des femmes de
l'Assemblée nationale pour moi c'est
important de venir en délégation et de
venir constater sur place et rencontrer
parce que je crois que on a beaucoup de
travaux et d'audition finalement le fait
de venir rencontrer ça nous permet
d'appréhender
les fonctionnements qui qui marchent
tout simplement au cours d'une année 213
000 femmes sont victimes de violences
physiques et sexuelles elles sont 93 000
victimes de viol ou de tentatives de
viol